[Musique]
quelques minutes ou plusieurs heures à
patienter pour un cliché Michael qui n'a
peut installer son appareil toute une
nuit pour une photographie un travail un
regard qu'il pose en voyageant sur le
patrimoine
[Musique]
c'est un goût de l'enfance il a toujours
aimé les paysages et donc pour lui c'est
son univers personnel c'est un il se
définit lui-même comme un romantique
donc il aime décrire les sentiments et à
travers le paysage il exprime
ses sentiments
[Musique]
un travail en noir et blanc pour créer
un univers particulier 50 clichés sont
actuellement exposés au Château de
Rambouillet 50 clichés pour 50 ans de
carrière tirées d'une carte blanche
commandée par les centres des monuments
nationaux souvent on pense photo
documentaire qui permettent de faire la
promotion touristique de nos monuments
donc on a cette mission on a beaucoup de
photographes qui font cela mais parfois
on fait un petit pas de côté et on se
dit il faut aussi confier à des artistes
le soin de porter un autre regard
[Musique]
du Château de Rambouillet à celui de
Versailles en passant par
Vaux-le-Vicomte ou encore le désert de
Reds Michael Kena partage son amour du
patrimoine des Yvelines et d'ailleurs